hey guys it's max in this video we're
going to be comparing the brand new
homepod mini
to the new echoes both the standard and
the dot and the new nest
audio we're going to talk about the
different features we're going to listen
to multiple different songs
different genres and then i'll give you
guys my opinions and
which one you should ultimately buy for
yourself and which one i'm going to be
sticking with
starting out with prices most of these
are 99
other than the echo dot which is 50
bucks now right now there are some sales
going on so i'll leave some links down
in the video
description and i'm really interested
between these two because they're much
smaller
than the other ones now i do want to
mention build quality
the nest audio is built really nicely it
feels really premium just like the
homepod mini where's the echoes
right when you pull them out of the box
they feel really cheap the plastic the
cloth
the cable is just not very nice compared
to the other ones and then as far as the
power bricks they are huge compared to
the nest
and the homepod i don't know why it's
gonna be so huge on your wall outlet if
that matters to you
the homepod is the only one that has a
removable power brick that you can also
use for your iphone and because of that
because it's usbc you can actually use a
power bank outside
if you want to move this to the backyard
where you have no outlet and you can
still listen to it which is nice
and then you can also use a different
power adapter to charge multiple things
including the home pod
as far as controls the echoes have
physical buttons on the top what makes
it nice and easy to see
and use whereas the homepod has this
little touch surface
but you do see the minus and plus and
you can just press it to
invoke siri and the nest is really
frustrating as a touch surface
and even though i looked at the tutorial
it's still frustrating to use because
you don't really see
what you're touching now the nest also
has this little switch that's a hardware
disconnect
for your microphone so if you want to
have privacy you can flip that which is
nice
and you can also turn off the mics using
the button on the echoes
but the homepod you don't have the
option the last difference i'll cover
before we get into sound
is that the echoes do have a three and a
half millimeter output so if you want to
connect it to a regular speaker
or a receiver you could do that where
you can't with these other two
all right guys now let's get into our
first sound comparison this is a song we
often use and all of these are no
copyright songs
so go ahead and put on a pair of
headphones if you have them and let's
take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
painkillers
[Music]
[Music]
oh
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below i'll
give you guys my opinion
let's start out with these two since
they're the same size and
wow you can't even compare them the echo
dot
it sounds defective when you put it
against these these other two
the highs sound really bad the mid sound
really bad they're not rich at all and
the bass is non-existent whereas the
homepod sounds fantastic now comparing
the homepod to these two larger speakers
we definitely have a difference in
volume these actually peaked at about 81
decibels compared to
78 decibels at about five feet away
using my apple watch
so the homepod got 78 and the echo dot
was at 76 decibels so we have that
difference in
volume now as far as the sound quality
compared to the echo
and the nest well the homepod is
somewhere right in the middle the nest
has really clear
vocals the vocals sound great but it
lacks in bass
and then the echo the vocals aren't as
clear it has really nice
rich deep bass you can actually feel it
in the table whereas with this one
you can't you actually feel more bass
from the homepod
mini now let's take a listen to our next
song this is a rock track and with rock
you have a lot of different
sounds that are mixed together and vocal
so i'm curious to see how these will
compare
both the nest and the regular echo they
have a three inch woofer and then a
dedicated tweeter compared to
the echo and the homepod that just have
a single speaker
so i'm really curious to see how it's
gonna sound and for this test
i'm also gonna normalize the volume so
we're not going to listen to the
differences in loudness
just the differences in sound quality
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that test was really telling
first off the echo dot sounds terrible
if you care about sound quality please
don't buy the speaker second i was
really shocked by how close the standard
echo was
to the homepod mini in terms of sound
quality
now the homepod did have a little bit
more bass and
the homepod was a little bit clear on
the highs
with the vocals there and i like that
but they were so close
and next the nest really sounded bad in
this test much worse than before
the electric guitar really stood out the
vocals really stood out but the sound
wasn't balanced we were really missing
the drums
and the bass guitar there it just didn't
sound balanced at all it did not sound
great another difference i noticed is
that all of these three speakers here
they are directional and i haven't
pointed to the microphone so it's fair
but the homepod has 360 audio so it's
actually
pushing some of the audio back this way
and all around which is great if you
have it centered in a room
or even if you have in a corner it can
actually take the radiators in here
that aren't speakers but they improve
base and bounce that against the wall
and forward to you which is nice
all right now let's jump into our third
test this is a mix of classical with a
little bass
as well so put on your headphones once
again and let's take a listen to all of
these
normalized and i'm going to leave out
the echo dot
[Music]
so
[Music]
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section below
and with this track i felt like the nest
sounded a little bit better
i still think it was a little bit too
sharp in the high frequencies and lacked
a little bit of bass
but the song isn't as difficult and for
these other two they once again were so
close i feel like the homepod was
excellent in the mids and highs maybe it
could use a little bit more
bass whereas the echo could use a little
bit more of the higher frequencies
and the bass was maybe slightly too
powerful but still they are
very very close i am surprised
and i think both of these are great
choices so let's get into
the verdict and which one i think you
should buy and which one i'm going to be
keeping and
using now one thing we didn't cover is
the smart assistants
and they all have them the homepods is
the least smart i guess and it's also
the most locked down in terms of
smart home devices they're gonna add the
echo can i think do sixty thousand
devices now compared to thirty thousand
with uh the nest and then the home pod
is somewhere in the five thousand range
but the benefit is
you have better privacy with the homepod
all those devices
have been authorized by apple it's a
little bit easier to install
so that's a benefit but if you're just
looking for
the most compatibility the echo is
definitely the way to go
now as far as sound quality and using it
as a speaker
if you're just looking for background
music you don't want to fill up a whole
room with sound you don't want to be
able to dance to it with loud music
the homepod is excellent it's the most
balanced i'm shocked by how good it
sounds for a single
driver it is really nice now along with
that if you want
loud sound you want a little bit more
bass this thing is a lot louder it's
going to fill up your room and it costs
the same amount it's a lot more
compatible
and it has the output as well so it's a
more capable speaker now for me
personally
i'm gonna be going with the echo i like
to have much louder sound
you could stereo pair two of these and
you'll get close to the sound of this
echo
but then you're spending twice as much
money so let me know your thoughts which
one would you buy
down in the comments section below once
again we have links to all of these
thank you guys for watching this has
been max
and i'll see you in the next video